der zweck heiligt die mittel würdest du
diesem sprichwort zustimmen dann bist du
vielleicht ein magna will ist herzlich
willkommen zum teil 2 unserer serie zur
dunklen triade nazismus psychopathie
machiavellis muss obwohl diese drei
eigenschaften oft zusammen auftreten
widmen wir uns heute einer dunklen
eigenschaft und zwar via realismus der
name kommt von herrn machiavelli
italienischer staatstheorie ticker und
diplomat dessen erfolgsgeheimnis man mit
dem satz der zweck heiligt alle mittel
zusammenfassen könnte macht zivilisten
sind manipulative menschen die für ihren
eigenen erfolg sprich wirklich bis hin
zu buchstäblich über leichen gehen
würden underwood von house of cards ist
ein fiktives aber perfektes beispiel für
einen kalten machthungrigen magna will
ist ein durchtriebener abgeordneter der
vor keiner entriegelt zurückschreckt um
die macht in washington an sich zu
weisen wir versuchen die weltherrschaft
an uns erreicht leider ist das nicht nur
fiktion den psychologen glauben dass
materialisten auch in der echten welt in
der politik gut vorankommen dass sie da
ihre opportunistischen fähigkeiten ihre
geschickten heuchler reihen zum einsatz
bringen können
die heuchlerei ist auch genau das
gefährliche am aktivisten denn obwohl
machiavellis muss wie die anderen
eigenschaften der dunklen triade sozial
höchst unverträglich sind weiß der marke
will ist ganz genau wie er sich sozial
korrekt zu verhalten hätte und ist nicht
selten ein meister darin dass
vorzugaukeln
du siehst toll aus die neue frisur steht
dir blenden sondern darf ich dich um
einen kleinen gefallen
der markt betrachtet andere menschen
eher wie objekte wenn sie ihm nützlich
sind werden sie entsprechend ausgenutzt
doch darüber hinaus fehlt es ihm ähnlich
wie den rassisten oder dem psychopathen
empathie menschen mit ausgeprägter
dunkler triade auch weniger
beziehungsfähig so gibt es studien die
psychopathie und materialismus mit einer
höheren neigung zum fremdgehen
korrelieren interessanterweise suchen
psychoaktive listen er gleichgesinnte
als partner
während narzissten es selten mit anderen
narzissten aushalten denn du liegst
nicht mehr nein du liebst mich mehr denn
ich lag auf
hallo bei allem leid dass die dunkle
trio zwischenmenschlich anstellt sind
menschen mit diesen eigenschaften kein
fall für den therapeuten man spricht
hier von so genannten sucht klinischen
ausprägungen wäre nazismus und
psychopathie in ihren extremen formen
als persönlichkeitsstörungen
diagnostiziert werden können gilt
machiavellis muss selbst in seiner
extremsten form nicht als psychische
störung
glückwunsch sie sind ein riesen arsch
aber psychisch offiziell gesund so soll
die dunkle triade in jedem fall stecken
wenn auch in verschiedenen ausmaßen dazu
einen philosophischen frage an euch was
lenkt die ist der mensch von natur aus
gut oder böse und denkt ihr steckt die
dunkle triade in unseren genen oder ist
vielleicht ein produkt unserer
gesellschaft lasst mich wissen was ihr
denkt
falls ihr teil 1 dieser serie zum thema
nazismus verpasst ab das video gibt es
hier bzw auch unter dem link in der
beschreibung zusammen mit dem kleinen
psychotest wo ihr eure dunkle triade
messen könnt den dritten teil zu
psychopathie gibt es dann den es hier
deutschen schlage sein bleibt brav